[Music]
my mom's work ethic was incredible
although ended up giving her chronic
fatigue syndrome which I need to be
careful
of when you think about being raised by
your mom what are the things that she
told you over the years that really
stuck with you um it's never the end of
the world that's empowering for me
yeah um treat everybody equally or with
respect um because you never you you
know that saying like be nice to people
on the way up because you might meet
them on the way down yeah and
um I think it's just taught me I'm not
afraid to get my hands dirty and I've
always I've done I've been there I've
did I used to wash up plates in a calf
till my once my nails fingernails all
fell out like I'm not not ashamed of
grafting and getting in in there so I
think think that and and my mom's work
ethic was incredible although ended up
giving her chronic fatigue syndrome
which I need to be careful of so I've i'
I've seen the flip side of work holism
as well um what kind of a mom do you
think you would be um I'm very maternal
I've got a bit of a reputation for um
taking lots of people under my wing and
you know like one of my backing singers
came to live with me for like a year and
I'm quite sort of people come to me to
be looked after or to help me put things
in perspective so I think I would be
quite nurturing and um I'm full of love
like I just have a lot to give so I'm
looking forward to having somewhere to
put
it